let's talk about something a little more
current shall we the overwatch I guess
already access started yesterday the
open beta is getting rolled across
global territories as we speak I think a
lot of places probably having oh yeah I
thought is Thursday Oh is the Thursday
it's happening I think may fifth okay on
what day is today it's my third oh it is
may the fourth is so I think it's May
fifth for all three platforms early
access soon enough i will be able to go
and pick it up themselves let's have a
little chat about it briefly I've been
playing it on the beta for what seems
like an eternity now and are you
reviewing a for us or not you know I
will be ok fur for all I know that's the
plan cool an iron have you played and
your watch at all I played some
overwatch yeah cool plane to the beta
and so what are your thoughts on it so
far mike has somebody who you were gonna
review the final product I feel like
we're basically playing the final
product yeah- anything they change with
the progression and the skins and just
overall I don't know just servers map
rotation writing give life stuff perhaps
yeah this game is it's got me hooked I
think because of our jobs it's tough to
really play one game all the time
anymore which you know it's you know it
sounds like such a thing come online
about yahoo right that's it's not a big
problem at all but like i'm looking for
like counter-strike i'm looking for you
know we have rocket league but i'm
looking for that shooter i can just go
back to time and time again and its
really got me hooked each of its
characters it feels like they could have
a game revolving around them I think
these characters so nuanced and so
detailed and so so much thought but into
each one and then when they collide the
balance is so great and you think about
each match a different way depending on
who you're playing or what the objective
is there's so many like minor things so
many major things you don't even notice
just because it's such a such a chaotic
looking game but then a certain point it
kicks in when you know a few characters
and you know what you're doing you know
what your team is trying to do where it
just starts making sense in such
different ways each time and yeah I'm
looking forward to putting a lot of time
into this I'm totally with you in terms
of like we were talking about
battlefield vietnam earlier and then
there were games like you know
counter-strike 1.6 i was big into i love
source i love team fortress 2 there is
these sort of tentpole first-person
experiences online games that I sort of
have we all have rifle
we look back at our our history of our
our favorite games and this is as close
to one of those as a game has come in a
long time like probably like call of
duty 4 modern warfare like this is a
game that I can see myself playing for
like a year or two and and it's because
of what you just said it's because there
is such a I mean like you can never tell
right when Randy pitcher was up talking
about battle born and we were seeing
these games like battle cry and an
overwatch was coming up from blizzard
and there's a sort of a cynical aspect
where you're thinking oh you know what
it's just somebody else who's trying to
get into another multiplayer game which
to trying to hook in people to play
forever and it's gonna be like a MOBA or
it's gonna be this like super reductive
thing and like oh it is all these
different characters that look different
so I kind of went into overwatch being a
little bit cynical thinking you know
what they're all gonna look you know
people are gonna look to cosplays these
people but I'm not gonna care i just
want to play a goddamn first-person
shooter but these characters like
they're so they're so individual and yes
all interest like and i genuinely mean
all I think maybe soldier 76 is the one
that I'd least play like playing the
least but I still enjoy playing him yeah
across the war 21 of them are so
interesting play like junk rata
sometimes play with I love fire and
Widowmaker but I'll just like jump all
over the place I don't mind when I'm
last into a brat into a team and it says
all you need to play his assault or I'm
support it's like fine I'll pick lucio
or I'll pick mercy if them if the map
works and i think it's like you know
obviously that team had a big a lot of
trouble with what they went through a
titan and i think they had a big way on
the shoulders to really make something
legitimately great and I think overwatch
is like legitimately great yeah it's I
think Scott's been playing a lot of
battle born I played a decent mount of
battle born and that's a game where
Scott described it I probably earlier on
the show I didn't catch it he was saying
you know it's easy to learn or sorry
easy to master but it's difficult to
learn whereas this one is it's difficult
to do both I mean it's the characters
are it's easy to learn but it's
difficult to master because these
characters they initially seemed really
simple but some of my favorite
characters you know it's it's this fine
balance between mastering these five
characters but also just it's so fun to
try someone out new and it's still the
game itself is very inclusive and how
you play it because it at the end it's
not it doesn't show kill death ratio it
rarely shows kills
it'll say like if you were a support
it'll say you healed this much team
damage and then everybody votes on like
what was the most useful and I think
that's a really cool way of showing how
this game works and that you don't just
have to be Widowmaker sniping people in
the face to help you can be zaria my
favorite character and shielding people
shielding yourself using your ultimate
to create these chokepoints where
everybody just starts like junk grass
starts lobbing grenades and you know
while mercy revives your last teammate
it's it's it's just like refined chaos
and it's so cool and how it unfold
differently each time and what initially
seems like a simple game yeah I think
the way that they're tracking your score
and what information they choose to
display or not displayed to you it came
up in your interview was a really good
design decision I can't tell you how
many games encourage bad player behavior
because they're so obsessed with their
KD you are they're so obsessed with
their point total and it actually will
get players to be selfish and not play
the objective and them choosing what to
show and not just show based on making
players more emotionally connected to
just focus on the objective like don't
worry about it don't worry about your KD
don't worry about these other things
like those are very forward-thinking
design decisions that I think encourage
good player behavior totally and even to
things like not including team damage is
also a part of that where it's like they
could easily put team down watchin here
you don't you know you probably wouldn't
they as a support character but they
literally do not want any situation in
which you get back into like bad habits
I think team deathmatches is the death
of objective based gameplay right
because what usually happens and has
happened in a lot of shooters is you
have an extensive unlock tree and you
have some great modes and you have
deathmatch and people realize that death
matches the quickest way to get through
the unlock tree and by the time they're
done with it they're like whatever I'm
just keep playing deathmatch yeah you
kill the objective modes and I've seen
that happen in battlefield and lots of
other games so it's very brave dan on AB
deathmatch and it's a decision that I
think more games should follow I mean
like we I guess when this first came out
we sort of frame it in terms of a lot of
new games and the sort of new things
that are happening in first-person
design especially an online competitive
maybe not shooters but just online
competitive play but this is like such a
best of of you know so many first-person
shooters I mean Widowmaker has the
grapple hook from quake to you
no junk rot is basically a team fortress
grenade spammer you know lucio runs on
walls like so many games you've got
tracer who's basically you know Corvo
from dishonored right diva is tightened
for like all of these characteristic you
know even like widow-makers sniper rifle
feels like it's a headshot home when you
it's like hammer strike it's like you
can hit people the body and then certain
at a certain point you're playing
against people who really know how to
play Widowmaker I was like oh no I need
to go for headshots yeah there's people
that will grapple hook and then mid mid
grapple just yet sniping in the air will
likes life you including that little
like cool damn thing that happens about
it I will say you do have to like a
style of gameplay that revolves around
Chuck points a lot yes because it that's
one it's one very specific thing about
this game whereas in battle born the
maps are very open and strategically if
you're not put if you're not successful
pushing one side of the map you can
shift to the middle lane of the left
lane whereas in this one I feel like you
live or die by certain choke points in
this game and the deciding factor a lot
of times are some of the characters who
can go up in over buildings yes and get
behind the enemy team but there's also a
lot of players you're just like you
gotta push through this thing then if
you can't do it matches over yeah
totally is it very like Team Fortress 2
in that respect or team fortress classic
or whatever quake World Team Fortress
could be fun to go to whole way back
yeah however far you want to go back
that's why it overwatch is really I'm
traditionally a an offensive player in
in battlefield so offensive yeah I
offend people when I'm shooing them I I
guess it's always offensive right this
game I actually like playing support
characters a lot probably the most um
you know zaria I think she's classified
as a tank but she's very much oh yeah in
her aesthetic and how she plays but
she's very much support in the way she
could she could shield people and like
you're just time I chokepoints I'm as
someone who's really into like
multiplayer level design it's cool that
her ultimate is essentially them letting
you almost create these many choke
points yourself with a black hole yeah
pulling a bunch of people in i think it
was the one match I really realized how
cool this game can be it was on the
payload we were almost there we were
escorting the payload and I was tracer
and I was just playing her like like a
dual wielding first-person shooter game
um and then I realized like oh no I
could I should be a pest right now I
should just go back to where they're
spawning almost I don't have to kill
anyone I just have to just annoy them
yeah hasa keep them occupied shoot them
one about to die back out to the next
room keep running away shoot them just I
and it was awesome because I was just
you know like I was skirmishing wasn't
killing anybody and I know I i know they
hated me for it because they couldn't
get back to like my team it was doing
their jobs and you know way to winamac
Widowmaker above us we had Farrah just
kind of watching the payload from above
we don't Winston circling it and then I
was just off by myself going rogue and
kind of just essentially annoying the
other team it's a med that the memorable
moments that you get in this game remind
me so much of playing games of cs where
you've got like four v1 right and you're
watching spectator mode and like CS
italy and you know the other player just
figures it out just like isolates one of
them done gets two of them done like a
random grenade throat it just kind of
works out and then you know there's a
fight in a you know in a market and
there's melons flying everywhere and
then they end up winning like it's got
those moments but on a such a like
moment to moment basis that you know
it's a I kind of feel like whatever any
game especially when you preview I'm so
hesitant to talk them up because there's
a sort of thing where it's like oh
you're press you got all ready access to
this thing we playing in 4ever playing
on the great conditions but we've been
playing overwatch so much over the past
couple months and i have like absolutely
no hesitancy and saying that i think
this is one of the best online
first-person shooters that's compassion
like a decade i keep its almost i keep
having to remind myself it's not out yet
because i played its right and something
for three weeks it's not until May
twenty-fourth yeah so if you're a crazy
person about 130 taller edition or you
get the origin sedation for 60 and you
suck on be playing for for officially
for until until then but you know just
like hard stone you're able to just go
play it openly now I guess or soon
enough yeah i mean the you're saying
counter-strike and i agree with that
comparison the one game i've been
comparing it to my friend asked me
because he saw over watching he's like
this just looks like a MOBA to me like
like what battle born is doing with a
couple of their game was like no i was
like just think of team fortress 2 but
instead of five classes or whatever was
six you have 21 and they're all much
deeper the map there's more maps and
he's I got you already you had me
brightly and again i'm reviewing and
tempering what I'm saying yes but I've
had fun
but I don't have a final opinion the
game but i also have been playing a lot
of it I'm hooked on it all right well
there you go what's your thoughts on it
you've played it sort of you dabbled
yeah it depends where you're coming from
if you are like a battlefield guy who
likes this type of game to me siege
landed with me better just because i
love i love how and like the intensity
of CH and the fact that is the first
game in a long time that you're not
making a lot of kills and everyone
killed that you make matters a hell of a
lot to me that's more exciting than just
a really well-done mova style shooter
but that that's just because i like
tactical shooters and i like battlefield
and I like the sandbox better than I
like the choke point like it's funny I
dad did you play brink oh not not much
at all because I feel like brink tried a
lot of this stuff and for some reason it
didn't land with people and it seems
like overwatch is trying very similar
things and connecting with people yeah
so like you're right the player movement
stuff was very much in the early days
for first-person shooters back then as
well so I you know I think that I know a
lot of people love this game in the
office choke points are not for me I
like open layouts where I can make
decisions that are just go through that
right or die you know and that's what I
like about season that's like about
battlefield and I've got a lot of games
look forward to this year do you like I
mean like Titan Neal I don't know when
titanfall 2 is gonna happen we're gonna
find out at e3 dhoom3 is a couple weeks
away as well yeah but I respect other
people's enthusiasm for this game right
now and I did enjoy what I played yeah
I'm gonna play more siege that the
interesting interesting week 44
first-person shooters interesting month
and yeah maybe hopefully an interesting
year as we get to the end i would call
of duty and let us know what you think
are you gonna pick up over watch
yourself are you gonna jump into the
open beta edge sudhir from people who
are playing it this week for the first
time actually and let us know what you
think in the comments
you